alright guys bangbang I've got rich here
he doesn't know I'm gonna say this but
uh I think that you're probably
recognized as the best TMT analyst on
Wall Street is that flattering it's
flattering but is it true some people
will say that some of them some would
say most hated but you know it just
depends on your perspective in life
alright I just wanted to get that out of
the way right out of the gate I got a
whole bunch of stuff I want to talk to
you about first of all let's just talk
about your background and how did we get
to a light shed because you spent the
last what nine years or so BTIG but
what'd you do before that I mean I've
really spent 20 I guess this is 24 years
plus analyzing media stocks I started at
Goldman Sachs right at reddit college
loved the media space I mean you know
Mike is infront of my mouth as I'm
talking to you I mean I was running the
college radio station up in Boston at
Brandeis I was calling basketball games
I almost went to Newhouse to do sports
broadcasting and ended up in finance
because that was my other passion was
finance and sort of have combined the
two of media sports and finance all into
one which is you know covering the broad
media tech space and started at Goldman
spent eight years there have been in a
couple of other firms in between but the
ideas always been about covering media
and tech companies and so I've been
covering names like Disney going back to
1995 and so it's been a long history of
looking at the space and seeing the
evolution I like to say that you know my
first two months on the job at Goldman
Sachs Disney bought a VC so just to kind
of frame like just how far back in
history you go and you look at the
consolidation that's playing out now
with Disney buying Fox and 18 t buying
Time Warner I remember one time Werner
bought Turner so I used to carry Ted
Turner's bags to conferences and so you
know it's been a long evolution but you
know the realities I think it gives us
really unique perspective on the space
to look back over you know a 24 year
plus period and see how this industry
has evolved because there's been a lot
of change
you know I'm we're sitting here on a
podcast and you think like my
first year at Goldman in 95 the only
thing technologically going on in the
media space was the creation of the DVD
and the predecessor to DIRECTV was
pushing satellite television at the time
and that was technology in 1995 and now
we could spend hours talking about
technology's impact on the media space
and really have technology sort of
infused and really colliding with media
yeah and part of what I think people
really enjoy about your analysis both
kind of what you guys did professionally
but also just on Twitter is your
understanding and kind of how you pay
attention to both the public stocks and
things us covered but also your
understanding of the private markets and
a lot of what's going on there and those
trends etc and you blend them together
pretty nicely yeah I mean look we met
Evan Spiegel it's snapchat when it was
20 people and we really try to
understand where the world was going and
I think you can't do that in the media
space broadly without really getting
into the early stage startups that are
playing out and we've seen that time and
time again of how all of this disruption
has impacted I mean look at what Netflix
I mean you think about Netflix which was
a DVD company when I first started
looking at it and now you look at how
every media company is evolving you you
have to really spend a lot of time on
the startup community to understand
what's gonna impact these big public
companies not just from what they're
gonna make acquisitions in but just how
it's gonna impact their business and I
put everything on from it everything we
do focuses around the consumer what is
the consumer doing how is consumer
behavior changing and how do you make
money off of that and you know we you
know become an active angel investor I
think you know things go well we'll
launch light jet ventures over the
course of 2020 but we have a lot of
ambitions to be a lot bigger than we are
now but it all comes back to its driving
this kind of ultimate flywheel of you
learn more from the private community I
think it makes you a better analyst in
the public markets in terms of how do
you analyze these companies and get
smart on these companies and you you
know that also creates more windows into
what are the things that are missing or
what are the missing pieces or problems
that the public companies are facing
that the private sphere can address or
try to fix and I think you're seeing
that flywheel really
and I think it's been from our research
standpoint I think it's been what really
differentiates us because I don't think
a lot of people focus on the private
sphere sitting in my job absolutely
couldn't agree more just so people know
light shed just kind of what do you guys
do so as we get into some of the more
nuanced topics they've got that
perspective yeah so my whole career has
been about covering stocks so buy sell
hold ratings on public media and tech
companies and I started light shed with
two partners Walt aiesec and Brandon
Ross who work together with BTIG for a
decade the three of us and and two other
colleagues left in July and in September
started up light shed and light shed is
essentially in its initial creation is a
research platform so we're writing
research at light shed TMT dot-com we
are building out our research
description business we will add we were
talking before the show talking about we
want to get our own podcast started in
2020 we want to build out light shed
ventures but what you see today is
essentially a Content business focused
on helping our clients our subscribers
make money in the media and tech space
guide and most of those are all focused
on public markets I wouldn't say that
actually I know there's plenty of people
who are you know I think that the value
add of our content applies across a wide
spectrum and so you know the reality is
there's fewer and fewer investors today
even if their focus is public market
investing more and more of those firms
are making private investment because
the companies are going public later
you're seeing a lot of companies stay
private for a long time and you're
seeing a lot of what you would think of
as very traditional public market
investment funds allocating a portion of
their portfolio to private investing and
I think you know our you know access to
private companies is a real value add
for a lot of investors no matter whether
they're in the public sphere private
sphere or across across the to for sure
before we get into what I think is more
of the mainstream topics I want to talk
about some of the new media models that
we're seeing the first and probably the
one that I think about the most is
partial sports so for those they don't
know barstools a we'll call it a sports
blog has kind of how it started out
versus newspaper then we call it comedy
more these characters for sure
but I think comedy really infuses and
what what differentiates it is the
comedic take on sports content
mm-hmm I don't think you could look I
don't think you can say sports without
comedy I you know if you wanted to say a
sports comedy fine but I think would be
unfair to call it sports B it's not
about going it's not where you go to get
the scores it's no it's not where you go
to get the analysis of last night's game
the way an ESPN would break it down or a
bleacher report break it down this is
where you really go for kind of the
comedic take on everything that's
happening in the world the wide world of
sports globally especially the more
entertainment chart which is definitely
driven by the comedy but what they've
now morphed into they took an investment
from czernin then they brought in you
know kind of professional leadership
they've really built a big business
about a hundred million dollars in
annualized revenue now and they just did
the deal with Penn to kind of Penn
gaming Penn gaming to push more into
kind of the gambling component of that
that sports world what's your general
take on one you know that deal with Penn
and then also to why no one's really
kind of copied what they've been able to
do is it driven by the people behind
this or kind of what's that magic sauce
that they have that others have been
able to copy you know look I think one
of the real challenges facing digital
media publishers is trying to build a
brand that really means something and I
think you know this is not just go to
college campuses this would be walk into
and you know walk into a Wall Street
trading floor walk almost anywhere on
the East Coast Midwest and even parts of
the west coast and you know you'll see
you'll walk into a dorm room girls and
guys and you'll see bar stool
merchandise barceló postures you'll see
chicks in the office yeah you'll see so
much barstool branding you know I don't
there is such a passion for the brand
and I think that's what's really
important is that Dave Portnoy and Erica
Nardini of the CEO they've they've
really understood they have this
passionate connection with the listener
with the watcher which the reader and
that can translate into many things and
whether it's selling merch whether it's
tuning into a serious radio show whether
it's using the app whether it's showing
up I mean if if Dave Portnoy told
everyone to show up in Union Square New
York City at 5:00 p.m. tonight
just because there'd be a crowd of
people not knowing why they were lined
up but they would go do it that's
something that's really powerful in the
media world and you you think about what
you can do with that passionate loyal
fanbase and there's lots of things and I
think one of the things obviously with
the pen saw in this transaction was the
ability to drive them instead of going
to draftkings or to FanDuel drive them
to pens apps to gamble especially as
mobile gambling and mobile sports
betting takes off over the next you know
take a lot of time for legalization to
play out across the entire country but
state-by-state you're certainly seeing
it in New Jersey you know obviously
FanDuel and draftkings have dominated
this space if you want to break in
branding and being able to use a media
business a broad media business to drive
people from one to another I mean I
think port noise on record basically
saying in many ways he helped build the
FanDuel and draftkings directing people
to go there now he can direct people
elsewhere and I think he's got a loyal
and a following where they're gonna
follow whatever he wants them to do
obviously within reason but I think that
that passion for the brand and I also
think what's really interesting about
barstool is they've rethought the model
you know most media businesses that you
and I have grown up with tend to rely on
advertising and this is one especially
digital media businesses and I'm
thinking you know if you think about
historically the vice is the refinery
29s I mean you go through the list they
traditionally rely on advertising and I
think more and more of them are now
converting into studio businesses but if
you see bar Stoll they really you know
from a very early on it was commerce and
transactional from a merge standpoint
was a huge part of their business and so
really rethinking media models I think
is why the bar stool case study is so
important for every media company
whether or not they like the content of
bar stools a whole nother thing seeing
how bar stool owns the customer how
they're able to use that or to push that
customer across their properties
leverage one podcast into another
leverage one event into another people
that actually mean how many meet digital
media brands do you actually want to
wear the t-shirt I mean I think of
wearing the t-shirt is a huge
determination of success like if you
want to wear a t-shirt of a digital
media brand that really means something
and I think there's very few where you'd
actually want to wear
that brand and people would go oh my god
you're so you know I'm a stoolie - yeah
I so I looked at the deck that Penn
gaming put out on the acquisition in 31
percent and 32 percent it's about 63
percent of the total revenue of the
businesses in podcast advertising and
merchandise and to me it was that it was
so backwards compared to every other
media company in the world right they
were quick to get on podcast they've got
a number of the top 50 podcast on the
world and then the merchandise component
and I don't think that a lot of the
mainstream media right can do
merchandise because their brand promise
is very different right it goes back to
this kind of fanaticism that people have
with the bar stool Brant the New York
Times can't be pushing merchandise onto
subscribers because it's just it it
would violate that brand promise I mean
look I think ESPN had an incredible
sports brand that people probably would
have worn when I was growing up mm-hmm I
mean I don't think it's I think it's
very different now I think ESPN to most
people now means a live sports event
that they go to to watch a live game on
you know a Saturday evening a college
football game or a college basketball
game I don't think they think of the
brain in the same way that they used to
but I think a lot of media brands are
like that I mean MTV doesn't mean what
you know what I think about what MTV
meant to me growing up and you know you
know tuning in for the the top hundred
video countdown in TRL right here I was
you know or you know think about the
grind and and South you know spring
break with MTV that my friend Andy shone
helped build and that's a brand that
really meant something to an entire
generation now I think Spotify is that
type of brand you know for you thinking
about a media brand or music brand in
2020 Spotify has far more kind of that
cool factor that you'd want to wear the
the Spotify t-shirt far more than the
MTV t-shirt and I just think it's like a
lot of these digital or a lot of these
legacy media brands have not kind of
stayed up with what is quote-unquote hip
and cool for the consumer yeah we'll get
to music in a second but yesterday I
tweeted a photo I was in a Starbucks and
it had a were hiring kind of chalkboard
they had all of their
benefits outlaid and one of them was you
get a free online education from Arizona
State University you get you know 50%
off the food you get all these different
things and then one of it was a free
spotify premium account and it and I
literally tweeted and I said I don't
know if the free education or the free
Spotify account wasn't more valuable
right but depending on the demographic
Spotify actually may be the winner
Spotify has an incredible brand and you
know I think it's just you know it's
hard to differentiate music services
because they all have the same songs
effectively I mean some have more than
others but effectively you have access
to the world's music catalog and so the
underlying technology and the brand mean
a lot and I think that's what Daniels
been so smart to build as he's built a
brand that constantly iterates and I
think it's that constant iteration is
something that a lot of the traditional
media companies struggle with is they
don't live in that cycle of constant
iteration and I think as they've tried
to get into tech it's been one of the
real challenges they face it that they
don't they don't live on an every week
refreshment cycle for a new feature they
live in months if not a year cycle for
you know planning things and I think it
hurts them as they try to break into
tech yeah so this is part of the
barstool magic sauce right is this
something can happen they can turn
around t-shirts and merchandise et
cetera within an hour and literally get
it out people are buying it etc they
also added a subscription component so
people can actually buy in one of the
questions that I have is or you talk a
lot about the barstool brand but one of
the things that they've done that ESPN I
think did early on but kind of got away
from is barceló is really kind of put
these personalities on a pedestal right
so whether it's big cat or PFT
commentator all these guys etc can
somebody else replicate bar stools type
of success with just the model and not
have the personalities or do you think
all this kind of goes together
hand-in-hand well I think you're talking
to a broader theme of like news as a
category right you know think of the
innovation of Fox News Fox News is not
really about news I mean during its
primary money earning period which is
primetime
it's not about news at all it's all
about talk and it you know it's because
so much of the quote-unquote news and
information has been commoditized by the
internet that
where you really differentiate yourself
is in conversations like we're having
you know the actual kind of personality
driven side of the business and I think
that's what barstool obviously in a very
different context than Fox News but I
think it's where you know they've really
seen as a huge opportunity and Exploited
it is really defining the category of
you know look live sports is really
expensive and so getting in doing what
ESPN does where you're spending billions
of dollars in ESPN spends 2 billion
dollars for 17 Monday Night Football
games that's a very expensive business
that requires you know tens of millions
of people paying a lot of money in their
cable bill every month the bar so models
obviously a you know a very different
cost model where you're able to do a
tremendous amount with a you know
relatively slim content budget well
during those live games what are they
doing they're literally sitting in front
of a phone basically propped up and
they're filming themselves reacting to
the game right which it which is an
amazing hack as to how you get around
the the licensing absolutely and I think
parcel has been very creative and how
they you know play in the world of
sports without having to absorb the I
don't want to say absurd but the
ever-increasing costs of live sports
broadcasting sustained with sports
another new model is the subscription
and so you've got things like the
athletic that are popping up which the
data that was recently released after
their last private round is incredibly
impressive in terms of retention rates
and and monetization etc we've seen the
New York Times I think is the best
example in the mainstream press who's
gotten you know five plus million
subscribers now ESPN plus has started to
actually get people to pay and they've
got I think seven and a half million or
so subscribers is this where all of
media goes or is there still room for
the non subscription based business
model yeah I'm looking let's let's list
for a second let's just push ESPN plus
to the side cuz I think it's a little
bit of a new case I think if you look at
the New York Times in the Athletic they
both been great examples of you know
when you put up a paywall and you
basically tell people they've got to pay
for something and you have content
people want people pay now I mean
clearly the New York Times is benefiting
from you know adjusting how easy used to
be very easy to get content for free now
they've made it harder and harder and
they keep restricting how much content
is free before they force you to pay so
they
technically smarter understanding how to
market which people to go after I mean
near times is really invested in the
technology side of the publishing
business and so that they really
understand how does social market on you
know digital marketing campaigns how
they figure out how the conversion looks
like what churn looks like they've had
to learn essentially this new business
but it really is underlaid by the idea
that there is content that people will
pay for maybe it's not as many people as
we're reading for free online but that
there is our business of people that
will absolutely pay for these things and
like you've seen lots of examples of
audiences that will pay for something
you know look at a crunchyroll that has
several million subscribers for you know
for you know for Japanese anime the
athletic that you know when you take the
best writers on sports out of the
publications they're reading and say
this is the only place you can get those
writers and we're gonna give you those
writers access to all not just those
writers gonna get access to the best
sports writers from the key publications
all across the country that have left
their jobs to come here there's a group
of consumers that are tribal I mean
Sports is really tribal and if you want
to read the person you've grown up with
reading for the last ten years fifteen
or twenty thirty years you're gonna
subscribe to the athletic and the price
point of you know call it you know forty
dollars a year I think it was a sixty
yeah but I think there's lots of people
on promotions and discounts I probably
the blind is probably in that you know
thirty five forty plus a Costco
membership rate Costco I think sixty
bucks a year this is not expensive yeah
this is not expensive and I think there
look it may not be the scam I mean you
have to separate when you think about
subscription businesses not everything
is gonna be Netflix with a hundred and
sixty million subscribers not everything
is going to be you know Amazon Prime
with you know their global subscriber
base you have to put kind of the lens of
like is this a good business can you
create a successful business with a
group of passionate loyal subscribers
and I think the answer is absolutely yes
and I think that you know I've been
really impressed with the New York Times
I've been really impressed with the
athletic to date I think what Alex is
done I mean trying to prove people wrong
day by day who never said this could be
done and you know he's going into new
businesses you know putting podcasts
behind the wall for subscribers and
looking for ways of adding incremental
value expanding overseas and now they
have EPL content
going after the you know the English
Premier League diehard fans who are
probably even more passionate than a lot
of us sport fans are about their sport
so I think he's been very smart in
targeting the sports that have real
tribal audiences and going after
kind of the talent and locking up that
key talent in industry you know called
traditional publishing newspaper
publishing that's in you know secular
decline and leave The Times aside the
rest of the entire industry is in deep
trouble and it's not getting better
ESPN Plus I just want to come back to
you for a second it's sort of in a
different universe you know ESPN 8 plus
is sort of the the long-term
subscription life raft for ESPN I don't
think you know most people when you said
the seven and a half million subscribers
at ESPN Plus has remember most of those
people were subscribing to a triple play
bundle of Disney Plus and Hulu over the
last quarter interesting so before the
triple play was announced they only had
three and a half million subscribers and
then Conor McGregor I think brought
another million or so right so the point
is is that you know and that we don't
know what the longevity of that last
million is who came in from the McGregor
fight you can come on and off these you
know part of the problem with a lot of
these subscription businesses that it's
really easy you know it's it's the exact
opposite of taking a day off from work
and waiting for the the charter service
person to come into your house and
disconnect your cable and then having to
you know install it again and then sort
of a painful and just waiting on hold to
make that happen
to get someone to come to your house or
to go to your house is nearly impossible
so now you live in a world where in the
time it takes me to say cancel you could
go on your phone and cancel one of these
services and so the churn dynamics are
tremendously different in the
direct-to-consumer world and I think
it's a real issue as all of these
companies everyone wants to be in the
Netflix business everyone's season it
goes oh my god we we should be doing
that it's hard to be in the
direct-to-consumer business and there's
a reason why Netflix is creating as much
content is that they need to keep you
from leaving yeah because it's that easy
to leave and I think you know publishing
businesses in many ways are naturally
built because there's constant content
that's coming out you know look Disney's
got a great brand and there can be a lot
of people who just subscribe to Disney
Plus because it it ties to kids and
people want to have that around there's
kind of a constant babysitter but you
know terms of high profile content
or an adult there hasn't been anything
new on Disney plus since mandalorian
ended in December there's a new show on
Netflix every single day yeah and it's
very topical right I mean everything
from the Aaron Hernandez type
documentary to the latest movie or
they're originals etc it kind of spans
the gamut you know I think it's an
important reminder of if you're trying
to build a mass audience product and I
you know I want to think about mass
audience meaning something that can have
upwards of 80 90 million subscribers in
the US and hundreds of millions of
subscribers globally
you can't just reach one part of a
household I mean take Jon stanky who
runs 18 t you know a Warner media and
within AT&T and you know he's public on
record talking about the fact that HBO
didn't have enough breath to it HBO was
really great for someone like me I love
the shows on HBO but the reality is in
order to expand HBO their problem was
something like Game of Thrones ends and
you turn off you leave not me but lots
millions of people turn off when when a
big show ends because there isn't a show
every single day there isn't a show for
your kids there isn't a rom-com you know
there have to be titles for everyone in
the household and so you may not care
about you know to all the boys I love
you know number two or whatever this
show is but it's not for you it's for
someone else in your household it's for
your kids or whatever and it's
recognizing that in order to mitigate
churn in the new world you need to
become important to everyone in the
household all the time yeah and this is
actually what's so impressive about the
athletic the numbers at the last private
fundraising bedrock capita led the round
publish so much these numbers and the
churn after year one so if you get
through year one into year two is
actually staying above 90% or I'm sorry
the retention rate staying above 90% and
so it's just because it's so easy when
you see people staying for multiple
years in a row at these low price points
it goes back to this idea of like who's
winning the people who are actually
making things that people want look
subscription businesses are incredible
mm-hmm you know you look at the cable
bundle was incredible for a long time
right I mean think about how easy it was
you showed up to work and whether you
were ESPN or Discovery or
a MC or an e or lifetime or MTV or
Nickelodeon it didn't matter
honestly if nobody watched your channel
the night before money just rained down
every single day you me think about it
at the peak a hundred million people
were paying over $8 a month for ESPN and
the viewership on a nightly basis was a
fraction of that and there was a more
than probably half the base never even
touched ESPN over the course of a year
yeah
and yet you were paying a lot of money
for it and so the the the the challenge
that the traditional media the legacy
media world faces is that they'll never
be a model as good as TV's legacy
business model I mean you're never the
nobody you know I always think about
from a standpoint of Netflix how many
Netflix subscribers are there that don't
want it like that literally pay for
Netflix and don't want it numbers got to
be very small where there's lots of
people who pay for a cable bundle and
there's lots of channels that they have
no interest in including the really
expensive ones I mean when you realize
it's something like MSG networks that my
colleague partner Brandon Ross covers
like you're paying $8 a month for that
yes network you're probably paying six
to 650 a month for most regional sports
networks you're paying four to 450 or
four whether you watch them or not and
so there's a lot of very expensive
content that you're being forced to pay
for because of the way the bundle was
built in because these big media
companies owned so many channels and
they don't want to let you choose FX
without Disney they don't want you to
choose MTV without Nickelodeon and so
they kind of force the bundling together
and I think the reality is what's
happening now is the consumers saying
enough is enough all the best content or
all the most ambitious content is going
direct to consumer and consumers are
just finding new outlets for
entertainment and I think those out it's
not just things like Netflix and video
it's also the athletically you're
reallocating your entertainment budget
to a wider array of options and you've
ever had and not all of it is
traditional video the way we think of
video it may be something like headspace
you know or maybe common I think there's
a whole array of where you spend your
time apps they're gonna go well beyond
the the traditional video watching
experiences for sure
one other new model that I've seen and
have become a fan of his like the sub
stacks the morning brews kind of all of
the email direct-to-consumer type
content delivery businesses what are you
seeing there how do you guys think about
that I look I'm an early angel investor
in the scam and I think if you were to
look at things like the morning brew
that have sort of you know taking that
taking a different spin on that model
yeah I think it's in many ways it's a
lot like what barstools proven out is
that you have passionate audiences about
a topic lifestyle topic that you can
build real fandom around the real kind
of habitual behavior and use that
audience use the passion of that
audience for your content and do other
things with and so I think you know
we're still really early in that
evolution but you know I think if you
look at some of these brands that are
trying to replicate that level of
passion and use it to monetize across a
number of different ways whether it's
affiliate marketing whether it's
sponsorship there's a look that the
challenge that brands face it mean this
is a really serious problem not just in
the US but globally is as linear TV
viewership disappears unless I mean
disappears is a harsh word shrinks but
shrinks dramatically right I mean
there's already there's a hundred and
twenty million households with
televisions in the u.s. 40 of them don't
have cable television
so there's 40 million homes that you
can't reach on ESPN or MTV or Annie
anymore you literally cannot reach those
homes they don't subscribe and so the
challenge as this number keeps shrinking
and even the people that still have it
they're watching less and less so the
challenge for a marketer is how do you
reach consumers in 2020 and beyond and
we forget about where we are today but
what about in five years you know when
that ad becomes 60 or that ad becomes 50
how do you reach consumers and so I
think all of these brands are trying to
figure out yes you can spend on Facebook
you can spend on Google you can spend on
Twitter you can spend on snapchat but
everyone's trying to figure out how do
you create a real meaningful
relationship with a consumer and I think
some of these passionate audiences you
mentioned the athletic you mentioned
barstool you mentioned you know I
mentioned the skin morning broom in all
of these are trying to go after
passionate audiences and trying to
figure out a way to connect brands
advertisers in many ways with consumer
and take advantage of that some of them
are ad-free like the athletic we'll see
whether ultimately there's opportunities
for brands to play a role but I think
you know some of them are gonna shift
into them and obviously barsa you know
leveraging advertising on the podcast
side and then turning it into
merchandise sales
I think everyone's gonna have to figure
out new models because you know the
reality is advertisers are dying to
figure out how do they reach consumers
in 2020 because it's just getting a lot
harder to get the same reach they're
paying a lot more every year they pay
more for less and less reach and so the
question is how do you make up that gap
and it's a I don't have any crystal ball
I mean you talk you know you bring a CMO
on to this podcast this is a real
fundamental challenge that all of these
brands are facing no one has the crystal
ball right now of how to execute on that
yeah and one of the things to me you
know when we were at Facebook and
thinking about ad placements and kind of
targeting and all these things is most
people actually are okay with ads if
they're good at there's things that they
want to see they discover things all
this kind of stuff but one of the hard
parts about television for example is
it's really hard to do kind of the micro
targeting that a Facebook allows you to
do right and so one of the things I've
seen on the email side have you seen
this new one called girls night in or
have you seen this yet so my my fiance
started telling me about it and
basically it's a woman who created an
email she sends it and it's kind of
around the like self-care right so if
you're a woman you want to stay and you
want to do your facials paint your nails
all it's kind of stuff but it's
perfectly built to suggest products and
brands to people who are specifically
interested in this and so you see the
media like what michelle phan built up
on you know bring with her passionate
fan base and then built hypsi around it
and you know look the reality is
everyone is trying I go back to what is
where do we Center our research to all
around the consumer it's a war for time
and attention right I mean there's a
fixed number of hours and minutes and
yes you can multitask and you can be
listening to this podcast while you're
sending a message or snapping a friend
or whatever but the reality is it's a
war for climate attention and everyone
is trying to capture in their ecosystem
whether it's Google whether it's
Facebook the challenge the media world
uses is that the vast majority of the
traditional media world what I call the
legacy media companies and we're talking
in this case whether we're talking
Viacom whether we're talking Fox whether
we're talking you know go through the
list of you know even HBO and for the
vast majority of its subscribers and
even Disney for most of its
relationships they don't know who you
are they don't know who I am right I
mean they don't have a direct
relationship with us they live in a
world where they get Nielsen ratings and
the data you know ABC puts a show up and
they get a Nielsen report the next day
and it's extrapolated from 40,000 homes
of what we think people did the night
before whereas Facebook knows exactly
what I do they know exactly what I'm
interested in and when Instagram serves
me an ad like they did last week for
core power yoga opening up on the Upper
East Side two blocks from where I live
you know with a free first week it's an
incredibly we you know not only
interested in fitness and not only do I
you know I'm a peloton user and I go to
SoulCycle and I go to Rumble and like
it's an incredibly well targeted ad
whether or not I end up actually going
the fact of just how good that targeting
is versus compared going home tonight
turning on ABC and you're gonna see the
same ads that I see not to mention every
single other person in New York State
and other than the few local ads that
are inserted everyone in the entire
country
just seeing the same ads doesn't matter
whether you have interest in those
products or not and so TV in many ways
is the exact opposite of the Facebook's
and I think the the beauty of what
Facebook's shown especially with
Instagram is Sheryl and the team have
really built essentially the holy grail
of advertising right where they've
actually tied together advertising and
commerce like you actually want to buy
the products on Instagram it reminds me
in many ways of the ads in InStyle that
my wife would flip through and go oh I
want to buy that like you know the ads
are content I think the ads on Facebook
are content in it what the beauty of
that is you can have an infinite ad load
because you don't mind the ads you know
you actually like the ads you actually
want ads engage with them right
where's what was the last time you saw
an ad on TV Zico that was so awesome I
wish I could share that with a friend I
mean yes it happens I think about like
the Beats ad that ran before the World
Cup you know there are certain ads there
you go that was awesome hmm but it's
very few and far between
absolutely when we leave the ad world
and we get into the kind of streaming
wars that are going on I had to make a
list on a dead
okay-y well I just hate the idea that
it's a streaming war between each other
when I think the reality is is that
what's actually happening is consumers
are leaving traditional linear TV and
they're embracing a wide array of
streaming services like I don't think
Netflix is Gaines our Disney's losses
and vice versa it's not a
winner-take-all type market it will it's
because you have essentially consumers
we're spending five hours a day you know
go back a few years people are spending
five hours a day watching linear TV when
you shift that and they were spending a
household was spending upwards of a
hundred dollars a month and not to
mention they were buying DVDs they were
you know I mean there were lots of other
incremental spending on top of that the
blockbuster for sure they were buying
downloads and iTunes and on Amazon and
all of that and they were going to read
boxes in Walmart's and renting movies
and now entertainment dollars are
shifting to an array of streaming
services whether it's Netflix or Disney
Plus or Hulu or prime video and some of
them don't even have incremental costs
right I mean you are a t-mobile
subscriber and you know the team over
there gives you Netflix for free you
sign up for Verizon unlimited plan and
you're getting Disney Plus at least for
a year one for free and so you know this
idea that that that one's gain is
another's loss it's just a fallacy I
mean consumers are gonna have lots of
these services there may be three or
four that essentially core services but
consumers are gonna have lots of these
and it's so easy to go in and out of
them I think it's much less of a war
against each other and much more of a
war of wait why are you subscribing to
television bundle like why are you
spending $80 on a video service that you
really don't use except for live sports
and you know an antenna for most of your
listeners does a pretty good job of
getting them football you know live
football you know for the ones that are
diehard NBA fans or diehard MLB fans do
yeah they're probably gonna have to
subscribe to a YouTube TV or Hulu who
has live sports now when you watch that
Super Bowl spot and it's like okay the
reality is those are great services
right think about it from the consumer
standpoint if you're just a fan of the
NFL you can sign up for Hulu Live or
YouTube TV you can sign up from August
until February and then cancel you don't
need to be a subscriber for the full
year whereas no one ever call
of Comcast and canceled halfway through
the year so you have a whole new
behavior of you can manage not only do
you pay less than you would pay for a
video subscription on one of the big
cable companies or satellite companies
but it's also easy to turn on and off
and I think in a minute if you use the
experience of YouTube TV it is night and
day versus spectrum like I it's actually
hard for me to understand how anyone
who's actually used or seen the YouTube
TV product why you wouldn't be using
YouTube TV versus spectrum because it's
just a night and day experience I'm in a
cloud DVR and access across I mean the
fact that I could watch YouTube TV right
here any of my channels and the same
thing if I'm in Los Angeles versus my
spectrum which is essentially tied to my
house and is clunky even in my house
it's amazing these things are still
relatively small you know you roughly
call it 9 million of the 80 million
homes with multi-channel television are
taking one of these kind of over-the-top
streaming bundlers of channels which is
still I mean look it's big from zero but
it still seems small when you look at
just how much better the experience is
for sure how do you think about when I
think streaming coming from somebody
doesn't spend all day thinking about it
I go right to like Amazon or I'm sorry
on Netflix Hulu etc it's like Kleenex
which right there's certain brands that
matter most
yeah and just there that's streaming to
me but then when you really dig into it
there's Apple there's Amazon there's
others that are they're playing like
what's your kind of view of the
landscape when it comes to streaming
specifically around video outside of
live sports so don't forget out the live
sports for a second just when you look
at you know who's creating content what
are the platforms what kind of what's
each one's angle and how does that
landscape kind of play out over time
Netflix obviously it's all they have
right I mean their entire businesses
they need you to subscribe to Netflix
for the video content the bundle of
video content that they're aggregating
for you increasingly their own content
but it's probably 50/50 theirs versus
third-party and it's moving more and
more towards their own content over time
which is a great model because they have
the data they know what you want to see
they you know if you click on a rom-com
you're gonna get a lot more wrong
if you click on an international you
know if you click on Roma you're gonna
get a lot of international content the
you know the beauty of Netflix is data
but gets more data you know because you
can create a better experience you can
learn from it you can trial lots of
things I think the culture of testing
and learning and experimenting is
something that is so is so powerful at
Netflix and it's just not built into the
DNA of traditional media companies and
as they convert from you know linear TV
into the streaming world their greatest
challenge is understanding that it's not
just about putting a streaming
application up it's about learning and
leveraging the data and evolving the
model and seeing what people do and
being willing to cancel shows because
the price value doesn't make sense
relative to the number of means you
actually know how many people are
watching look you know theoretically
they know exactly how many people
watched each episode where they tuned
out where the problems were that data is
really powerful and it's something that
you know no company has ever no one's
ever had access to 160 million
subscribers households that's just
people but hundred million households
figure three people per household maybe
even more with password sharing there's
a tremendous amount of data that's being
aggregated but again it's not just
having the data you have to use it who's
like capturing data is one thing
understanding how to use it and I think
that's the beauty of what Netflix has
been successful at is using the data to
inform decision making it doesn't make
any show better like it's like it's not
like they can say they can't take a bad
show and make it better simply by having
data but I think they can learn what
types of shows people really like what
types of content what genres to go into
where to go deep how well is
international content working in one
market versus another what's missing
from the offering where could they add
more content I think that is really
powerful but to your question on like
the landscape overall you know you've
got Netflix by far the default kind of
clear leader in the category and you've
got everyone else kind of realizing you
know you've got obviously Amazon was
there early as well Hulu was there sort
of as last night's television originally
and I think increasingly as last night's
TV sort of goes away it's increasingly
gonna morph into more of an original
programming story much like Netflix so
you see you're seeing effects now if you
watch the Oscars last night a bunch of
ads for FX on Hulu you're going to see
more
more FX content flow into hulu over the
course of the next couple of years as it
makes that transition but i want to come
back to the philosophy here of like why
is an Amazon or Apple in this world it's
it's all about keeping you in the
ecosystem for a long time and attention
yes they want more of your time and
attention the more time you spend with
Amazon the more you're gonna purchase
like the only reason they do Amazon
Prime video I believe is not because
they'll I think it's for the good of
their heart they want to give you you
know free movies and TV shows like
misses my soul to watch they actually
believe that if you watch missus Mazal
that you'll end up end up spending more
time with Amazon and purchasing more
mm-hmm that's the reason I mean that's
why they do this content and so it's
about keeping you in the Amazon
ecosystem apples doing it because they
want the more time you spend with Apple
and Apple devices and if you come into
the Apple TV Plus app to watch the
morning show or to watch you know pick
it you know any of the new shows that
they've created the servant which was
you know very good and you look at this
content you go okay I'm spending more
time with Apple TV plus all of a sudden
you realize oh I can subscribe to HBO
through Apple I didn't realize I could
do that
let me subscribe to HBO through Apple so
now I'm something even more time on my
Apple devices and then I'm like well I'm
even more wetted and you know not the
churn is a problem for Apple which my
colleague well plastic covers but it
just keeps you in the ecosystem and it
creates a services layer on top of the
equipment that Apple hasn't had before
and so it plays into this how do you
build this robust services layer it's
through great content and people let's
go back to where we started with the
cable bundle people spend a lot of time
and a lot of money on video and so I
think it's the opportunity is to capture
some of that time attention and in turn
while its share for these companies in
their ecosystems and I think each of
them is you know they have different
goals
you know once the cell devices ones is
to kind of drive retail sales but each
of them is trying to keep you in that
ecosystem longer and longer even Disney
Plus I mean look the reality of Disney
Plus is probably to you know take for
the first time ever to mine data for
Disney so that they can hopefully in
success we haven't seen it yet but
hopefully in success they're sending out
to their members their subscribers and
they're saying you know would you like
to come to the parks we can offer
members a discount or we can get in
early to the parks or you know what are
the membership has its privileges
benefits of being part of the Disney
Plus Club we haven't really seen that
yet right now it's just about content on
the service but I imagine over time that
this will go far beyond just simply you
know a subscription fee of 590 or $6.99
a month yeah so two things one is the
membership model obviously drives
revenue and in this short term you can
easily see how I'm gonna look at data
I'm gonna use that to create new content
and give people what they want except
here but what you just hit on is kind of
this connection between the subscription
to receive digital content and
everything else in an ecosystem whether
it's Apple giving discounts for products
whether it's Disney getting you in early
or just kind of pricing whatever to
their parks to showings in person
whatever it is I don't think that a lot
of people have done that yet not just
Disney but just across the entire
landscape it doesn't seem like that's
something that they're pushing is it
because you need to build up critical
mass first and then you kind of pull
that trigger or is it something else has
kind of holding them back from kind of
jumping into that that connection of
subscriber to other types of services
and experiences it's a really good
question I mean if I think kind of
holistically about the question you're
asking I mean certainly a company like
Disney has been the best at making use
of it right I mean you create movies and
then you build theme park rides around
them so and then so stuffed animals and
clothes and dresses from Halloween right
and so there's no doubt that they're you
know when you build brands or you umbral
IP that there's lots of ways to monetize
them when stranger things came out there
were lots of people buying Christmas you
know stranger things you know sweater
sweaters and and Christmas lights and
there is no doubt that there are ways to
extend successful brands just as we were
talking about when you were in the bar
slow conversation everybody's trying to
create IP that can be leveraged above
and beyond the core business they're you
know this is not just about the video
subscription business it's about
understanding the customer you know look
for a company like Amazon it may be
enough to just know that you know this
is one more reason you don't leave the
prime ecosystem which has a lot of value
to Amazon in terms of purchase behavior
but they're also probably learning a lot
I mean we haven't gotten to music yet
but when you think about you know what
you listen to in music what you watch on
you know on video probably says a lot
about who you are and what types of
products you're interested in I think
you can learn a lot about people from
their media life and so that you know
that information that data can be very
powerful
when harnessed properly a friend of mine
recently brought up he said to me you
want to know how valuable Netflix is and
I said how and he goes what's it cost
per month and I said $9.99 that's what I
signed up that right now they've had
like - price increases except I don't
even remember that they moved it right
well 99
yes it's $12.99 now right and and he
basically was like that's how you know a
product has really served its purpose
for somebody is they remember the price
that they probably paid initially but if
that price is moved up you don't see
kind of a higher degree of churn you
don't see the elasticity etc yeah look
netflix grew slower this year and they
cited the price increase actually as the
key driver of why they grew slower grew
slower but not increase in churn um
definitely an increase in sure okay
there wasn't increase it was an increase
in churn but they didn't lose subs how
many businesses can raise price by 20%
and still grow subscribers yes churn
picked up and so they had to have more
gross ads to mitigate the churn but they
actually with a 20% price increase
Disney Plus and Apple TV plus launching
and remember Disney added 26 million 20
probably 22 or 23 million of them in the
US alone in the fourth quarter and
Netflix still added 400,000 subscribers
at that 20 percent higher price than it
was a year before and so you know this
is all about becoming so important in
your daily life that you can't imagine
disconnecting again the beauty of
Netflix right is it's easy to cancel
there's no contracts there's you're not
locked in if you want to cancel Netflix
while we're talking on the laptop that's
sitting in front of you it's really easy
to do yeah so you have to believe that
the the beauty of Netflix is the price
value is so good there no I mean $12.99
is nowhere near the right price I mean
just think about what they're doing now
if you whether or not you watch the
Oscars last night multiple Netflix
movies were nominated some of them won
but remember what does a movie cost you
I mean you go to the movie theaters in
Manhattan
a movie costs what at a minimum thirteen
or fourteen dollars oh it's more than
that yeah most movies are paying sixteen
seventeen dollars three two you're
spending over twenty dollars Netflix is
getting again the app the movie ticket
averaged just to level set the whole
country listening to your podcast movie
ticket price on average is ten dollars
per person okay across the whole country
matinee is included in all that kids etc
but still ten dollars per person for a
movie before popcorn before babysitting
before
Gasca gas or whatever pick your you know
pick your whatever it is ten dollars a
person here we're talking about $12.99
for the entire month for your whole
household for unlimited unlimited I mean
there there's a movie a week on Netflix
let alone a big movie probably every
month lots more to come they're just
getting started in their movie you know
let alone all of the TV series so yeah
they're losing friends but there's like
so much stuff that like you know I mean
try to go somewhere right now without
someone talking to you especially
someone in a little bit younger than the
two of us try to go somewhere with
people not talking about cheer
everyone's talking about cheer like
every single person is talking about
cheer a show that wasn't even on my
radar screen a few months ago and now
it's like part of memes and everywhere
you go people are talking about cheer
and they're talking about you sure that
failed on on a a literally was you know
it was a joint venture of Warner
Brothers and na na and now is literally
blowing it out on Netflix where all of
the content moved and I think it just
shows you consumers want to watch in
this new model and you know being
enabling people to binge has been
transformative to how people watch
television and I think a lot of the
legacy is still trying to force you to
watch week to week even as they do
streaming yeah people want to bench
and people want to be in science they
want to binge people want to be in
control of their viewing experience and
I think that's really the opportunity
but I think you go back to this when you
love something so much the and the price
value seems so compelling even when the
price goes up you don't leave yeah how
does that look through that perspective
for Disney Plus right so they came out a
much lower price point they got a ton of
sawdust right out of the gate I think
some people were surprised by how low
the price point was like how do you
think about that
$6.99 is an absurd price point for the
products right $6.99 it literally is
comical for what they're providing well
when you think about one new Disney you
know if you wanted to you buy blu-ray
version of frozen to when it comes out
in a few weeks you know that's probably
a twenty dollar product you know the
when when that movie hit streaming it
would go onto Netflix which again costs
far more than $6.99 and so to put all of
their kind of streaming movies and all
of the catalog Disney Channel and all of
that content for only $6.99 it was an
amazing price value the price point was
certainly lower than then we and you
know a little bit lower than we thought
I think definitely lower than Wall
Street thought overall the flipside is
is they didn't have a lot of content
right in terms of fresh content and so
it's a very library heavy service the
good news is kids like watching lots of
library they don't mind watching the
same Mickey Mouse Clubhouse show over
and over again they don't mind watching
you know frozen one you probably could
show to some you know five and six seven
year-olds girls like boys and girls like
they could watch it over and over and
over and over again they know the story
daughter so I just think of like you
know I think of my youngest and how much
how much she watched frozen the original
back in the day at that point you know a
digital version or probably a blu-ray
version but like the the the amount of
rewatching enabled Disney to have a lot
more value add to the consumer on day
one now the question I think really
becomes how long does that you know how
long before because not everybody
obviously is a family when you have 26
million subscribers that quickly and now
I think twenty eight point six if you
include what they have did in January
the question is is it is really easy to
churn and you know mandalorian ended in
December do all 28 point six million
stick around until mandalorian comes
back or until it's a Marvel Series in
August it's gonna be really interesting
to see the price point maybe low enough
we're churning was I think that speaks
to why is a price point so low it was to
mitigate churn as much as possible
until they could build up enough
original programming
and they'll never be Netflix so I'm not
sure the price when I'll ever be you
know fifteen or sixteen dollars but I
think it was recognition that there
wasn't a lot of kind of adult skewing
fresh content and they were really
relying on kind of the library at least
for the first 12 to 18 months to carry
them yeah I don't have kids but is this
a no-brainer have to have four parents
Disney boss I think if you have kids
under the age of 10 this is a very high
price value you know if you were in the
mode of having to buy one of these
things I don't even mean buy it on DVD
or blu-ray but if you had to buy one of
these titles you know Disney generates
roughly two billion dollars
backward-looking on home entertainment
so that mean that's the purchase either
digitally or physically of movies and
television shows if you were spending
you know to buy even just one of these
titles you know getting Disney Plus or
you know the annual plan is you know
call it $69.99 the price value is pretty
compelling you know instead of what you
were doing before mm-hmm I have you know
if if your kids aren't into Disney
Princesses or Lucas Films or Marvel no I
mean there's not enough original
programming above and beyond maybe
you're a NAT geo fan or you know look
I'm sure there's some people who bought
it just because it has the entire
Simpsons catalog available at a click of
a button look the number two show on
Disney Plus right now is and has been
has been Simpsons that's the crazy now
there's a lot of episodes yeah
that's right but you know it's sort of
ironic that the number one thing on
Disney Plus isn't even a Disney title I
mean they bought Fox to get the Simpsons
but I think it just shows you of you
know they're they're what this is a very
library heavy offering at least
initially I think they've got you know
we always thought that they had 20 to 30
million homes in the US was their
addressable market they got there just
four months shocking how fast they got
there yeah I think the question now is
if you want to move the price point up
or you want to have a far bigger
addressable market do you have to
diversify the content I don't think
they're gonna go there or the other big
lever that Disney has ultimately its
disposal is there's no reason why a
movie comes out in the movie theaters
today and it doesn't show up on Disney
plus for
six to seven months that legacy
windowing of the movie business doesn't
make sense to a consumer in 2020 and so
I think the ultimate tool and I don't
think Disney's going to talk about it
anytime soon I don't think they're gonna
do it but the ultimate weapon in their
arsenal is to shrink windows and I think
it's ultimately very consumer friendly
because remember you go to the movie
theaters they don't know who you are
either
they don't know that you went to see
Avengers they don't know that you went
to see rise of Skywalker they don't know
that you know they don't know that you
tuned that or you know I would assume
most people don't walk out halfway
through the movie you might have really
been disappointed in it but imagine you
were subscriber to Disney Plus and that
movie was available two weeks after it
came out and after the first half of the
movie you actually just stopped watching
mm-hmm
that would be incredibly data
informative to Disney they don't get
that data because they live in a world
of movie theaters where you know they
don't have any relationship with you the
end customer and so I think ultimately
that the quest for data is gonna drive
everyone to move more and more in this
direction Netflix is starting at
obviously you know just as they did with
binging they started you know movies
direct-to-consumer without kind of
skipping the theatrical window and
sometimes they're forced to do short
theatrical windows but ultimately the
goal is to get you movie content far
sooner than they otherwise could yeah
well switch gears go to streaming music
we I think we've seen a huge push by
Spotify in recent months but obviously
Apple music prime etcetera how do you
guys think about kind of music in the
lens of that like war on time and
attention you know it plays into this
overarching
audio thesis actually it goes beyond
music is music or audio has become so
accessible right man we're all walking
around with kind of you know almost like
computers in our ears with air pods I
mean everywhere you go you see people
with you know air pods in you see smart
speakers in people's homes you see them
you know I mean the price point for
these things is like almost free I mean
like there's so many things you sign up
for now and they send you a smart
speaker as part of signing up for
something like it's hard not to have a
google home device or an Amazon Alexa or
we know pick your service then you have
a theory on our phones accepting our
phones and then then take the where
where is two hours a day of audio listen
to the car and between Android
auto car play you know LX is getting
into the car you know it's getting
easier and easier to voice control in
the car and these interfaces are getting
better and better that the time spent
with music it's it's just easier you've
taken all the friction away from
listening to audio content and if you
think about audio it's not just music
right I mean what do you listen to you
listen to you listen to music you listen
to news you listen to talk you listen to
weather I mean sometimes you even listen
to sports I think it's fairly natural
that all of these activities are moving
from kind of a linear terrestrial radio
world into a digital world the the
beauty I think of podcast much the way I
think of talk radio right I mean if you
wanted to listen you know I think of
back in the day you listen to Howard in
the morning and you know the reality is
now you can listen to this podcast
whenever you feel like it you don't have
to be at certain place at a certain time
just just like the same innovation is
video right like I don't have to tune in
at 8 o'clock on Tuesday I can watch that
show whenever I want to watch it because
it's available on demand to stream on
any device anywhere I go you walk into a
Starbucks and you see someone streaming
the crown it's no different than someone
walking around with all the music both
you know music and talk news content
that podcasts enable and so I think if
you think about this this experience
it's it's taking what was a lot of
friction you know to go out and buy an
individual album usually only wanted a
song or two and it's moving from an
ownership model to an access model and
it's it's really very similar to the
same thread that you saw in video where
you know you'd buy a DVD and it would
sit on your shelf collecting dust and
now you know you could how many people
bought friends DVDs never really watch
them and then you look at Netflix where
there was non-stop watching of friends
on these platforms because it was just
so easy yeah so you take all the
friction out of the business model or
out of the consumer experience and
people use it more and some music I
think has never been listened to more
than we have right now the economics of
the business are just beginning to get
better you know it took a long time you
know if I look at consumer spending on
music in the in 2019 essentially we're
back it was up a lot you know up
mid to high-teens in terms of overall
consumer spending but you're back to
levels of like 2004-2005 it's it's taken
a long way to build you know you yeah it
collapsed you know I think of you know
in 2000 is where things really started
to get ugly by 2000 2008 it got really
ugly you know declines of you know 20
plus percent of consumer spending on CDs
and taking a long way to build out of it
but the model of access that you know
Spotify I think Daniel X deserves a lot
of credit it never would have happened
without you know the perseverance of one
entrepreneur who just literally wouldn't
give up in the face of incredible odds
an incredible push back and look where
we are now yeah a lot of people don't
know that how much push back that they
actually went through and kind of the
legal threats and all the things they
kind of bands we're pulling songs and
albums and I mean it was brutal I mean
think about Taylor Swift was in you know
I don't want to say an enemy of Spotify
but certainly was pushing back and I
mean it we've gone through multiple
iterations of talent having to get
comfortable that that this world is far
better than the old world and you know I
look at it now and I go we're just you
know Spotify has got a hundred million
subscriptions Apple's got over 60
million there's a bunch of other
services out there from Google and
Amazon and you even got things like you
know even tick tock trying to do
subscriptions in certain developing
markets music I mean musics gonna have
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
paying subscribers all over the world
and obviously price points are still
really low but there's a tremendous
opportunity because you're spending you
know people are spending so much time on
these streaming services and I think
going back to your point you made before
about Netflix as you spend more with
these services as you know it's not just
about music as its podcasting as it
takes on more of your your day your push
back on pricing disappears we haven't
seen you know Spotify has raised price
in one market so far they try to in
Scandinavia it went very well they
haven't done it yet but at some point
Spotify is gonna raise price of course
in major markets and especially family
plan subscribers you know people who
were spending $15 a month I mean I have
five people on my family plan in my
household and I mean there's no chance
whether they were charging 15 or 17
wouldn't matter you know that's a very
sticky customer because they love it
and I think the brand really matters I
think Spotify has done a great job of
building out what it means to be a
subscriber to that brand and everyone
else is playing catch-up everyone wants
to be in that pole position what's
interesting is there's been a couple of
attempts you mentioned Taylor Swift
jay-z with title I think Drake at one
point was very kind of hey Mike Conda
it's gonna be available one place and
not another I think Kanye's done that
etc every single one of them has caved
at some point right because ultimately
what ends up happening is the artist
seems to realize having my content in as
many places as possible is actually
better for me than me trying to put that
the function of the music model right so
even video you don't go touring right
like the the ultimate goal of a Brad
Pitt is not to go on a tour right like I
mean he made write a book and go on tour
but like it's not about touring right
like the old they're usually trying to
get out of it get away from people right
right so my point is like I don't mean
to make funny but like you know the goal
of the movie business or the TV business
is to make money in that business to get
the next product right so the
exclusivity I mean you're used to things
being a game of Thrones was exclusive to
HBO and we're kind of used to that in
the music world you essentially wanted
to be on every radio station you want it
to be on you know you wanted to be at
every retail store for some people to
buy your cassette then CD now the idea
of like you want to be everywhere and as
visible as possible because ultimately
you want to go on tour and that's where
you make the real money right like where
you keep 95% plus of the ticket sales if
you're you know at elephanta mighty may
make 99% of ticket sales when she goes
on tour that's the incredible you want
to be in that Live Nation ecosystem
touring all of those venues all over the
world that's where the real artists
money is and so from that standpoint
limiting yourself to one service or
another doesn't make a lot of sense if
your goal is reach it doesn't make sense
to be on one service I think it's in
many ways it's why the NFL if you think
go back you know the NFL has sort of
shied away from making any of its
content exclusive to the shriman world
and has really pushed not even for the
cable they've wanted to really basically
be on broadcast TV because they want
reach but it's all about reach I think
if you're an artist you really live in
the world of
reach and you want to be available I
mean the beauty of what Spotify does
even versus an apple right is that you
don't even need to pay a subscription to
be on Spotify there's a free version
that's ad supported and you can
literally hit you know essentially
anyone on planet earth with a phone can
listen to Spotify you similarly you know
you look at Amazon Prime you know most
people are not paying for the premium
Prime scription for music they're just
literally they have an Alexa device or
they have some form of smart speaker and
there's all the all the catalog meetings
stuff that six months or older is just
available to stream on demand as part of
an Amazon Prime music subscription and
so that reach element I think is really
important in the music space and I think
is a large reason why you haven't seen
these exclusives by and large haven't
worked
what's the ad models look like in terms
of like dollars compared to the
subscription so first Spotify and Amazon
etc is the ad component of their revenue
material or not really starting to be
you know I think Spotify was actually
increasing meaningfully I mean I think
and I think Spotify a few years ago
didn't I think first of all the labels
wanted to kill it
yeah of course right so they wanted to
go hey look at the Apple model can't you
be more like Apple why are we having a
free product that you don't subscribe to
I think Spotify is done a really good
job of proving to people mathematically
that if you get people in the free
funnel they love the product you get
them addicted they upconvert at a very
healthy rate from free to paid over time
doesn't happen instantly but it happens
over time Spotify has proved that out
and you don't hear labels or I don't
hear labels the way I did a few years
ago trying to kill Spotify free if
anything I hear the reverse of wouldn't
it be great if Apple had a free funnel
to drive even more people into the Apple
music paid product and Apple doesn't do
ads you know they're not really big on
data usage and so I don't think it's
ever gonna happen but I think it's
interesting that music and you sort of
gone full circle of we hate the ad for
the ad based product now that's a great
driver of the paid conversion and so I
think Spotify really taking the
advertised the ad driven product far
more seriously now they did a few years
ago if you have a lot of you know they
iterated it a lot in 2018 started to
bear some fruit in 2019 you're starting
to really see
talk about how much momentum you're
seeing you know for a company of Spotify
his age for monthly users to literally
be reaccelerating shows you something's
something's working right did that free
funnel is really starting to take off
and they're adding more paid users than
the year before so sort of that kind of
flywheel is really kicking in and I
think the labels get it and I think the
labels obviously they're seeing their
valuations go up I mean Universal sold a
10% stake at an incredible valuation to
ten cent net you know which was you know
the vendee sold a 10% stake in Universal
Music now one or music's trying to go
public I mean we're music is hot again
it's been a long time since music was
hot and I think that's really
interesting in terms of you know the
idea of shifting proof of as you shift
from an ownership to an access model you
can actually make a lot more money
alright we gotta talk about Warner Music
because I didn't realize this but when
they announced recently that they were
gonna try to go public it was bought it
was brought private for about three
point three billion dollars within the
last decade and now the latest private
valuation was thirty three billion so
ten acts in terms of multiple
appreciation who knows what they'll end
up going public at but is this a I'm not
gonna speculate okay is it is this a
Warner is hot and Warner has a great
business and therefore this is a good
time for one or two go public or is this
more of a function of frothy public
markets this is a great time if you're a
private company to go public if you've
got a good enough business that the
public markets want you know you have
north of 200 million people subscribing
at some price point to music if we one
posit believe that people are gonna
spend more which I think both of us do
that you're spending enough time on
these things maybe not all of them but
the good ones you're gonna spend more
money on per month and then the question
is just how big is the tami the total
addressable market how many people
worldwide could be spenders of music you
know I think that number is still you
know for somewhere between 200 and 250
million households paying now could that
number be double or triple the universe
that's currently paying apt when you
look globally how early Spotify and
Apple and Amazon are and so many of the
in Google Music YouTube music I think
there's a long way to go and so you know
I see why
people are excited there there is a real
opportunity to you know first of all
leverage the data in a very different
way so you actually know I'm the other
thing to remember is when these
companies to your point on going private
these companies were quote-unquote fat
right like they were cost fat so now
because of the the change in the
business they've been forced to get
skinnier they fired a lot of people just
to put it in plain English they fired a
lot of people they've become much leaner
organizations than they were a decade
ago and the revenue is starting to
explode and subscriptions are much you
know as we you know mission is a very
good predictable business and I think
it's one that investors you know I look
at the long history of the cable
industry people and even how people
think about Netflix people love
investing in subscription economics and
musics essentially being driven by a
subscription economics and so I think it
makes that content increasingly valuable
and you know in a media space where a
lot of the media ecosystem is sort of
collapsing you know so much of the
ecosystem is built around the cable
bundle and cable networks and publishing
and you know you look so many problems
here's a bright spot because musics
already gotten killed they're on the
comeback trail video we were talking
about videos going from a hundred
million people who were subscribing to
cable television in the US we're down to
80 remember the last time we were at 80
was 2000 so you know we're just we're
retrenching back now we're gonna go
towards what 60 million 50 min I ask you
like how many households in this country
have a have at least one diehard sports
fan like where you need I don't just
mean you need NFL but you need
everything like you need ESPN you need
Fox Sports you need the regional sports
networks like how many homes is that
well I'm gonna flip the question just a
little bit in the sense of not only do
you have to have a die-hard but also
your die heartedness is not served by
seeing the highlights on Instagram or
something else it's great I totally
agree and that's the problem right like
there's a whole generation growing up
with YouTube highlights and Twitter
highlights is more I haven't watched
SportsCenter literally every single
morning I would wake up early and watch
and I would try to walk out of the door
right after top 10 at the end of the
hour right and I was kind of our okay
let's go to school my brothers and I I
not watch SportsCenter in at least seven
years right I've seen every single
highlight on Instagram right how's the
highlights all these things so the
question so the question is is is that
number I know it's not 80 million oh
yeah it is probably closer to 50 than it
is to say 50 is it 40 is it 30 I mean I
you know I think a lot of the lot of
companies that I talk to believe it's
somewhere in the 40 to 50 million range
but that means the current universe of
households paying for multi-channel
television is gonna have yeah so so cut
in half with a lot of the costs that
we're talking about meaning sports costs
fixed so you think about what that means
and you go video is on the way down
that's why everyone is shifting and
trying to jump into the
direct-to-consumer streaming market that
these so-called streaming wars that we
talked about before musics coming out of
it right they've gotten destroyed they
took their pain that's why those sales
to lend a lot Nick you know happened for
Warner Music like this industry got
destroyed yep got leaner and now is
benefiting from not so willingly but
finally embracing the access model of
what Spotify pioneered and now they're
starting to realize like how much bigger
this business can be and you know you
you look at something like you know take
tick-tock right I mean look at the
amazing use case for music and so you
know tick-tock and Facebook and snapchat
all of these companies are starting to
pay for music right because all of their
products they're not music streaming
services but they all need music to
function and so as music becomes more
embedded in you know in other
applications it creates new revenue
opportunities that didn't exist before
for the music industry so there's just
more and more ways to make money than
ever before I mean who would have
thought that you know artists like Liz
oh you know blow up on tick-tock and you
know it's it's sort of just amazing
what's happening in the ecosystem and
you know in terms of you know where
there is so much creativity and I think
that's what makes music exciting right
now yeah tangentially related to that is
a podcast which still plays into this
whole argument right now yeah but well
here's part of it right so it's a mix
between kind of the trends in music but
also kind of that talk radio being
replaced by more of on demand put the
listener in control all those elements
are there
but we've seen two big things happen so
one is the anchor and gimlet type
acquisitions that Spotify is doing and
they're really kind of making a big play
in consolidating but then also we've
seen the bill Simmons of the world etc
where these are legacy media folks who
are realizing there is a new medium and
they're trying to go for a bar stool was
the same way right I mean port nine was
publishing a pamphlet in Boston he's got
but he but he goes into podcasting like
I think everyone realized three plus
percent of his revenue comes through the
African what's amazing about podcasting
is it's so intimate right like you have
you have us in your ear right now I mean
most people are literally they have a
little device in their ear and they're
listening to us in their ear I mean it's
so personal and you get to know the
hosts you get to know the conversation
there is you know I don't care whether
it's a you know host like you or whether
it's storytelling like you see on
something like serial you know full
disclosure I'm a wandering investor but
I like you know listen to the shrink
next door I mean there's just incredible
audio storytelling this is like you know
we're still at the early stages I mean
this is a 1 billion dollar revenue
business in advertising in that 1
billion dollars but the numbers I'd
recently just saw Rogan 30 million just
on the advertising of the podcast
there's a crew crime or something like
that that did about 15 million and then
Dave Ramsey 10 million dollars a year
just on the advertising but what was
shocking to me that second one I forget
the name of the podcast they did fifteen
million dollars in advertising via their
podcast and the report I saw was they
did 40 live shows last year where people
paid to come show up you know a couple
hundred people at each one and then they
also have a $40 a year annual membership
where fifty five thousand people are
subscribed to get special episodes
behind the scenes AMA etc when you start
to look at that that starts to look a
lot like a Disney with the IP and
monetizing it through different channels
etc but it's all audio based and
creating characters or stars from
personalities I mean look I think you
know podcasting is gonna be a natural
place where people look for IP creation
and so you know I went to the peacock
which is NBC's you know their version of
their streaming service that they're
launching it'll be out in you know soft
launch in May and bigger launch around
the Olympics later this year
but one of their big launch programs
that they profiled was dr. death which
is a onesie show you know one dream
murder show that they're turning into a
TV series and you know I think you know
you're seeing podcasts permeate culture
I think you know I don't whether
podcasting becomes super successful
simply because of the ad dollars that
are behind it or the subscription
higher-end subscription premium services
you look at a company like glow dot FM
is trying to make it a lot easier to
sign up for these premium subscriptions
that podcasters launch like you
mentioned or does it become just IP
monetization through you know other
ebooks and TVs and who knows I I don't
think we know yet all we know is that
there's a lot of great brands being
created people love listening to
podcasts they love that they can do it
on their own schedule any free moments
of their day they can you know plop one
on and start and stop whenever they want
and the ad load is reasonably light and
you know you can skip the ads if you
don't like the ads and ultimately the
ads are gonna get more and more I think
you know one of the things you'll really
see innovation why starting with Spotify
is starting to make much more dynamic ad
insertion so you're hearing ads that you
care about right now podcasts it
basically ads have been baked in and
often or times are not relevant to me or
you that's gonna change over the course
of the next 12 months and I think
Spotify is kind of planting a beachhead
like this is a category that they know
they need to win people listen to a lot
more than just music why would you want
to just be anything about the radio in
your car when you get in the morning
drive like you're not just listening to
you you know even if you were listening
to z100 back in the day and the zee
morning zoo right it wasn't just for the
music you were listening to the host and
the banter and like there it's far more
than just music I think that's what
Spotify realizes that it's you know you
want to provide a complete audio
experience you know they dabbled in
video for a while I think they realized
that that's not where they're that's not
where the expertise is or Spotify really
can excel especially as you think about
taking the advertising side of the
business more seriously it's a natural
place to play in and go after podcasting
and I look I think these podcasts it
reminds me of the early days of radio
because you have the ability to have
this relationship you know it's funny
how we're talking about parcel as we
started this off when you think about
podcasting it's that relation
ship with the host you think about
Howard when I think of Howard Stern I
think of Snapple to this day look I just
think of Snapple I don't know if you do
but I always think of Snapple it's Joe
Rogan in cash app yeah sure yeah so
brands become so attached to these to
these hosts and it's such a personal
relationship and they have such kind of
passionate audiences and just like
Portnoy and what he's able to do I think
that's the power of this podcast mean of
them is that you have this passion and
it's gonna get easier and easier I mean
I think it'll get easier and easier to
monetize that fandom over time in terms
of the ad experience look where you'll
be able to save the ad or learn more
about it just using your voice I mean
all of that's gonna get solved over the
next several years it'll take time but
podcasts as a medium is still in the
very early days with a lot of growth
potential and it's a category that right
now I think the hardest thing about
podcasting I don't know about you but
it's finding the ones to listen to yeah
then discovery elmo's yeah is really
hard well and here's see another thing
right if you look at like Joe Rogan
who's the highest earning podcaster on
on earth as far as been reported but I
wonder if he makes more money doing the
UFC commentating and his comedy shows
etc or through the podcasting I don't
know I mean I look I just invested in
the company called pod Chaser that's
trying to solve this issue of discovery
man I think everyone's trying to
analytics well it basically they want to
basically be the IMDB of God cast it
basically help you find lists and and
what you should be listening to man I
think it's a real challenge of like how
do you find podcasts that you're
interested in most of its word-of-mouth
it reminds me a lot absolutely you know
he reminds me a lot of like the video
space right like there's hey go watch
this show or go watch this show now it's
like my wife gets old go listen to
Oprah's podcast or go listen to Katie
Couric's podcast like it's it this is
all word-of-mouth and I think there's
gonna you know there's a real
opportunity to help the consumer find
all because there's lots of content you
don't even know exist I mean we all know
Joe Rogan there's all you know there's a
few that we all know yeah but there's
such a huge tale of great content
finding it and surfacing it is still
really hard and I think Spotify should I
mean all of these companies are trying
to tackle this challenge so one of the
things that I've thought a lot about
just having a podcast is the ad model
has been pretty much a hundred percent
of the market
like we've seen in video Netflix etc
we've seen consumers start to pay in a
subscription model there's a couple of
people who are trying it with podcast
luminary etc their whole model has been
raised a bunch of money go get a bunch
of talent put them behind a hard paywall
and then upsell people into it and the
challenge is is just again go back to
your musician issue people most
podcasters are not doing it purely for
the fee they get for the podcast they're
trying to build their media brand and so
you know I think the the in some ways
does it make sense there should be a
subscription service for podcasts that's
ad free sure yeah
theoretically that makes sense the
challenge is behavior has been different
theoretically that the challenge right
now is that most podcasters I know want
to be as famous and visible as possible
and paywalls don't help them like even
the you know the reality is yes Spotify
has a paywall but there's a free version
that you can get access to every podcast
that they offer for free I mean there
may be a couple of exclusives that have
like a staggered release but essentially
everyone can get access luminary I think
look Loomer he's gonna have to prove
that they can getting aggregated enough
audience to make it worth it so that
podcasters put their best stuff behind
the paywall and look they just brought a
new management Simon comes from HBO he
certainly understands premium content
you know he just lowered the price first
thing he did in the door was lower the
price my guess is to get the number of
you know subscribers up because you in
order to entice talent you need a much
bigger net to entice Talent yeah because
it's almost like and I think some of the
numbers they were paying people we're
pretty hot like seven figure type deals
to go behind that pay wall but you can
Monali do that for so long and - even
the money doesn't speak as much as if
you have if your Spotify right you've
got 100 plus million people whatever
listening yeah I think it's less about
the content behind the paywall then it's
what catches zeitgeist right like you
want you know if the content that's
behind the paywall is the zeitgeist ii
content that's amazing and people will
come in and i think people would
absolutely pay the you know right now I
mean what Spotify is trying to do right
is they're trying to create content
that's only available on Spotify as a
way to get you off of because the rook
the main platform where everyone lists
the podcast I'd say I assume 60 plus
percent of your audience is right now
listening on an apple podcast
applications 55 to 60 percent I think
you fine so the vast majority of people
are using the Apple podcast app that
hasn't evolved much over the course of
time doesn't allow for sort of any fancy
form of monetization and so I think the
the real opportunity that Spotify sees
is how do we get you off of Apple
podcasts and into Spotify and we're
gonna use you know exclusive content to
the Spotify platform but again exclusive
still means everyone can access it
across the world but we're gonna try to
use that those exclusives to get you off
of Apple yeah it's still early days
their market shares clearly building
they also have a younger audience so I
think a lot of the younger skewing
podcasts are doing better on Spotify
than some of the older skewing podcasts
where people are more embedded in the
Apple podcast ecosystem and that's the
same thing that luminaries trying to do
and you know again I think it's really
early days let's see what Simon can do
what um what's your thoughts on the Bill
Simmons deal so he sold to Spotify I
think we don't know the number yet so I
you know it's the report was he wanted
200 million I doubt he got it but that's
that's what they were saying he wanted
uh you know I think until we know the
number it's little you know I don't say
it's silly it's hard to speculate on
kind of you know how big a deal this was
I think somatically though for Spotify
they are trying to aggregate enough
podcasts to be a major player in owned
and operated inventory where they
control the ad inventory they control
the experience and they can you know
show the market what you can do when you
move from you know whether it's host
read ads or embedded ads and move to and
you know imagine you the host of this
show recording seven different ads and
Spotify picking the one that targets me
the best and only serving me the ads
that I care about making a going back to
where we're talking about with Instagram
making the experience better making it
where you actually want to buy the
products where you could actually sell
the products I mean there's there's so
much opportunities from improving the ad
experience making it feel more like
content mm-hmm
they're not there yet but I think that's
the that's the rationale behind doing
this not to mention well I don't think
any of Bill's podcasts that matter today
will go exclusive or behind the paywall
I think there'll be new podcasts where
they try to create some unique
and that tries to draw people from the
Apple podcast platform over to the
Spotify platform it's all about trying
to move market share and give you
reasons most people I would assume don't
realize that they can listen to almost
every major podcast on Spotify mmm I
just think it's not where they've
historically they just they listen to
podcasts on most of them on Apple some
of them on an overcast or you know some
of them on you know pick your
application but it wasn't Spotify so I
think they're a big part of this is
education and having some really big
deal high-performing podcasts helps
people become aware of Spotify as a
major player and major destination for
podcasts yes I thought I was interesting
too at least the reports I read they're
gonna leave the ringers written sites
they're gonna keep those and keep
running them I'm assuming that that has
nothing to signal for Spotify is kind of
grander ambitions no just let the ringer
team do it but it was still interesting
a banana look I think you certainly
could imagine there being a lot of cross
promotion right so I mean there's no
reason why on the ring or website it
can't you know the if you want to listen
to a podcast I assume it'll be a Spotify
embed versus I don't even know which
player the ringer uses today but I would
assume it'll be a Spotify play or embed
just to again to hammer home to people
that when they go to the ringer and
they're reading an article about whoever
that you know they see that the podcast
is available in the Spotify platform so
I think again just as a barker for what
helping introduce people to Spotify as a
podcast player I think it makes sense
you know again I don't know the cost of
running yeah the the non podcast part of
the business but I assume those are not
very expensive
you know operations relative to you know
the scale of Spotify I want to talk
about a three social content platforms
Twitter tik-tok in kwibi let's start in
reverse order kwibi well quickly I
wouldn't really put it social yeah I
mean there will be a social layer to it
I mean to me so kwibi sort of fits in
the middle of the video subscription
platforms that we talked about before a
little bit of the advertising component
that we talked about before and this
reality that every single person you and
I know is living more and more of their
daily waking life on mobile devices and
Spada and sorry and kwibi is basically
going look we spend lots of time
with gaps whether it's waiting in the
lobby before you came and got me whether
it's waiting for the subway or even on
the subway there's lots of kind of
limited moments of time where right now
you know you can consume content on
snapchat discover you can consume
content you can flip through your
Instagram feed or your Facebook groups
or whatever it may be chat with someone
on iMessage or whatsapp all over the
world and I think it's just recognizing
that we have lots of white spaces in our
day and if we can create some compelling
content just like you watch YouTube
right I mean you think about the you
know the earliest start of YouTube was
very short form I mean now you get
content that's 20 30 40 50 min and now
you can even get really long content on
YouTube but originally YouTube was
really short content
I think it's recognizing we have lots of
these gaps in our day and would we pay a
modest fee that may even be included if
your things like a t-mobile subscriber
you know would you pay a modest fee for
really good content on your mobile
device no one's ever tried it you know
some people think Jeffrey's crazy the
reality is I don't think people know
what they don't want yet or what they
want I think if if the content is really
good and the service is really easy to
use I think people will come will say my
whole thing has been other than gedcom I
tweeted this the other day I don't know
very many companies that have raised a
ton of money pre-launch
and been successful and the part that
just on what kind of made me cringe a
little bit when it came to kwibi was
they ran a Superbowl ad right pre-launch
running a Superbowl ad I don't know if
they've ever if we've ever seen a co to
be successful doing that but doesn't
mean that they can't be the first but
still just you know the hype and kind of
all of the ads been etc we just gonna
see when they launch if it actually
translates to revenue yeah I remember
walking through CES six or seven years
ago five years ago long ago I remember
running into someone who goes the
content on Netflix is horrible there's
nothing to watch mm-hmm and you know
look I still get people that say that
there's nothing on Netflix and then you
go like people are spending households
are spending two hours a day yeah yeah
that's the median I mean like there's
households paying three or four hours I
mean there's more to watch than you can
physically consume ever
so look the realities it's all about the
content I mean that's really I'm going
with this if the content is something
that people find compelling if people
get addicted to short form storytelling
and again there's no there's really not
a lot of historical context to prove
Katzenberg right or wrong we know that
you know people went from watching
movies to watching TV we know that you
know there's lots of examples of short
form content and you know look look at
the whole gaming space I mean candy
crush is sort of a time killer between
meetings or you're bored at work and
it's a way to kill time how many people
have you walked by their desks and in a
big office building or watching youtube
videos that they find funny it's all
about kind of filling those gaps in your
day in your daily life I think if the
content is good it'll work if the
contents know good this will be a
failure it's fair enough tik-tok just
you know it's that the creativity is
amazing like it's literally amazing I'm
amazed it reminds me of you know I
remember talking to Jeff Dorsey sorry
Jack Dorsey early on Jeff is Jack's lost
brother I remember talking to Jack
Dorsey and I remember him saying that
the the Y vine was so creative is that
with YouTube you know you you
potentially hit record recording this
conversation and not that we're not
creative but when you're forced to hold
the screen and you're actually forced to
compose something in that case six
seconds tick tock 15 seconds it forces
you to be super creative like and I'll
see my daughter and I'll see one of my
daughters who will spend sometimes two
hours to compose a 15 second tick tock
really absolutely where they'll just
practice and you know two or three of
them will practice for hours trying to
get something just right the I think the
the like dant like dance type crash
stuff yeah yeah but you see the same
thing with comedy and other categories
and I think it's also aging up which is
really interesting but it's the create
yeah I think it's the short form and
this may even go back to kwibi as well
shorter form does force a level of
creativity you have to you know it can't
get good after 20 minutes it has to get
good really fast I give that if it
doesn't get good quick you're not gonna
watch you're not you know you're gonna
tune out and I think the tick tock you
know in 15 seconds you're forcing
incredible virality but it's also the
participatory nadir right you watch
something then you can take the music
and create your own and try to copy it
with all of your friends and then it you
know it sort of just virally takes over
and the speed at which people are
becoming quote-unquote tick tock famous
reminds me of you know when people were
you know when being a YouTube influencer
was like the be-all end-all and now it's
like being a tick tock influence remain
like YouTube should be a little worried
that like tick tock has gotten this big
this fast because I think a lot of the
elements of what are working on tick
tock music and comedy we're kind of
early kind of drivers of the YouTube
story and not that YouTube's going
anywhere and there it's a huge business
doing as we know now 15 billion dollars
a year it's a huge business but I just
think you from a creativity standpoint I
think they should be a bit concerned
that you're seeing such momentum out of
tick tock yeah the part to me that that
is really crazy is when vine first came
out all of the vine influencers all
moved into the apartment yeah right and
this is where you get the Logan in and
his brother and also but recently I saw
on tick tock there's a family based here
in New York the D'Amelio family which is
what Connecticut I think yeah two
daughters teenage daughters and then the
mother and the father and they put the
same playbook where hey the girls
started to get famous on tic-tock then
they started bringing their parents in
tagging their parents accounts it's you
know I think like the father's got like
a million followers on tick tock you ta
just signed the whole family not just
them they signed the whole family my
friends at UTA the town I believe and
you know you know you look at the I'm a
big fan of famous birthdays though at
the website in terms of just what's
happening in teen youth culture and
Charlie's number one on the list really
so you know when you look at kind of
who's popular and who's you know I mean
you know 15 year old is top of the list
top of the list literally number one Wow
in a Superbowl commercial right for
Sabra hummus for okay boomer yeah so
look you know
I think it is an incredibly powerful
platform that's again very early in its
monetization you know they're just
starting to get really serious about
advertising they just hired and Blake
came over from Facebook to run revenue
in the u.s. vanessa has been building a
team who came over from YouTube I mean
there is truly exciting you know just as
a platform of creativity and and you
know I think that again this is just one
more thing that takes away time spend
from watching linear television you know
we go back to where we started this
whole conversation it's the war for time
right war for time and attention and you
know if you're a brand marketer you're
looking at tick-tock and going
you better have a tick-tock strategy
really you better be figuring out like
how you participate like the NFL was
early I mean you know the NFL got early
into you know pretty early into
tick-tock realizing we need to be there
so you started this season they launched
you know they launched on tick-tock and
they've been you know pushing content
all throughout the season building up
their brand presence and you're seeing
more and more The Washington Post was
even earlier I mean you you know you're
seeing publishers realize they have to
be there and I think that you know same
thing with advertisers where eyeballs go
brands follow yeah what about a Twitter
we all spend way too much time on
Twitter talking about time and attention
and they've actually done pretty well
still growing etc but there's funny and
I've ever grown actually and I think
it's it's largely due to product changes
right I mean I think the product side of
Twitter's just gotten way better I mean
you go back four years ago and you
actually it was reverse chronological
right like reverse chronological in 180
character era 140 characters but I mean
like if you weren't actually watching
the site at that moment in time you
missed the tweet and you never saw it
mm-hmm now the tweets that I should see
if I open up my Twitter account right
now it's showing me things I should see
and the next level of this is you know
it's it's sort of silly that you should
have to know rich greenfield to care and
follow media investing which is what you
have to do it you'd have to find rich
light shed right now and follow me to
get my tweets as we you know Twitter
really breaks in to 2020 the big
initiative is topics and so you should
be able to follow you know media
investing is I don't think that topic
exists yet but conceptually you know
more and more topics like you can follow
fortnight you can follow you know
certain pardon my take is now a topic
you can follow and so it doesn't have to
be a tweet from that account it can be
you know I follow the New York Giants
topic and so now I see tweets not just
from the New York Giants accounts but
from you know beat writers and even
interesting people who are writing
something that that goes viral about the
New York Giants I'm now seeing in my
feet and so it in many ways Twitter was
sort of an awkward right like it was an
interest-based network that forced you
to follow people and the hard part was
finding discovery no different than our
podcast discussion right in terms of how
difficult discovery was the biggest
figuring out who to follow was one of
the biggest challenges Twitter had when
you signed on you're like oh my god what
do I follow what do I choose this and
how do I decide and if you didn't follow
the right people you actually had a bad
experience and you were less likely to
come back every day the easier they make
the the easier they make it be to find
the content you care most about and they
can populate your feet successfully I
don't care whether we're talking Spotify
and making sure that you see the music
you should see all of that the the more
it's same thing with Netflix right like
tailoring the experience so that you
have a good experience is ultimately
what causes you to come back time and
time again and creates that addictive
behavior and I think that's what in many
ways what twitter has been successful a
lot of investment in machine learning
and AI obviously shifting away from
reverse chronometer
demarcation line and it's funny because
Facebook was the first right I mean
Facebook coming from Facebook it was
like a no-brainer for them to do right
at Twitter to go to the ministry but
Instagram one of you first started using
remember the uproar yeah remember what
happened with Instagram when they
shifted away from Twitter was the same
thing there's always the user backlash
and then they realize oh wait this might
be better one 42 to 80 characters same
thing right right actually most people
don't even use the 280 yep most people
are not tweeting 280 characters but you
know it does create sometimes much
better content having that flexibility
mm-hmm absolutely
so like I think you know the key
takeaway from that from that whole theme
or thread right is letting machine
learning and AI take over is what
creates trust
the computers to give you the right
answer mm-hmm or the right content is
what becomes critical and that's what
Twitter is done a much better job but I
think it's why people are enjoying the
experience and that's why they you know
I mean it's you know it's sort of
amazing that you know Twitter which was
growing in the low single digits just a
few years ago when you know when Jack
kind of came back into the company they
just grew 21 percent in terms of you
know daily active users so I mean
actually daily active users on the
platform up over 20 percent sort of an
incredible story absolutely one of the
last things I want to talk about so Jack
has made a very kind of big stand on no
political advertising on the platform
Facebook has taken a different toll but
I saw you recently tweeting about
political ad spending being something
that is going to have to change because
of the drawdown in viewership on
television the popularity of social etc
I mean it's a great question you're
basically putting me in a box right at
like TVs dying where does that ad space
go what happens you know take it well
let me let me let you out of the box in
the sense of there politicians will
always spend right don't find somewhere
to spend money because they think that's
what's gonna end up getting them elected
etc how do you view revenue for these
various platforms especially from the
political side in the political seasons
if all of a sudden their main source for
that marketing goes away or at least
gets cut in half or or dressing you
draws down I feel like I asked you like
no it's just really hard no it's it's a
you know I mean it's sort of the same
question of like you know even if you're
a brand like you know yeah yeah where do
you go yeah I mean like think about the
car commercials that run on TV or they
forget about car commercials maybe you
know they think about a Dove soap
commercial like what does a Dove soap
commercial look like when no one's
really watching linear TV like it's just
all of these things are really hard
intellectual questions of you know kind
of how do you reach consumers and I
think politicians are no different than
a brand linear TV is dying it's still a
great way to reach lots of people so
even today
especially older people right I mean the
people that are cutting the cord and
moving the fascists away from the the
linear TV bundle are younger they're not
young but there's only younger you know
and so you can still reach lots of
people through linear TV which is why
you're seeing this incredible ad spend
on you know in terms of the the current
presidential race but it is an
interesting conundrum because brand
marketers can certainly spend on
Facebook as they love doing and
Instagram and tic toc and all of these
platforms but to the extent that you
can't advertise on on these sites it
really creates the ultimate conundrum of
like what are you supposed to do if you
can't reach people on TV where are you
supposed to reach people and it really
becomes an interesting problem look I
think in many ways you know I mean
Facebook still taking political ads for
now yeah but I mean I think but look in
some ways it part of the answer your
question like well if this is the
platform that reaches 2 billion people
on the planet Earth and they'll take our
money then of course we're gonna go
spend well no but it also shouldn't we
let them reach I mean if this is today's
medium it used to be TV it used to be
radio but if today's medium is this
thing called the Internet shouldn't we
allow them to and the number the largest
aggregator of eyeballs on the Internet
globally is Facebook you know Facebook
and Google should we not let them be
there and I think it's it's a really
tough challenge that you know I think
look obviously politicians in each
country are gonna need to put rules
around it and that's what Marx wrote Lee
wants is rather than stop it
forced governments to put rules around
it but I think it's a really hard
question I know I think it's easy to
just say no we don't want any political
ad spend you know I'm not sure that
solves the societal problem that you're
sort of raising which is how do you stay
informed about you know
people used to pick up the paper yep
right like well and this goes so I'm
gonna bring it full circle here two
things one is I saw recently there was a
politician does matter which one that
was
starting to pay influencers to talk
about them and the first reaction I had
was like what exactly is an influence
our gonna say that like make somebody
change their vote and then we saw the
Joe Rogan comment about Bernie Sanders
and it was like you know half the
country hates them all of a sudden half
the country supports them and you get
all of the kind of pull it
cool controversy that follows something
like that but if you kind of take that
even a step further if media starts
going behind paywalls rise to take the
New York Times etc I saw a study that
showed kind of the left-leaning language
has exploded with the New York Times
once they went behind the paywall and a
lot of it is just unconsciously you
begin to write for the subscriber right
and you change the way that you present
information because they can leave
easily right and it's almost do you
create these echo chambers to some
degree which ends up being bad for
society because the business models are
forcing that or is that something where
it theoretically the the fear mongers
you know talk about it but actually
that's in reality not what ends up
happening you know I've never done the
analysis to actually know whether yeah
of course she's quantifiably actually
prove what you just said yep it may or
may not be true and I'm not gonna debate
the point I think look the good news is
they're still you know even if you can't
run political ads on on Twitter there's
certainly lots of places to reach
consumers and you know they're solely
the ability to build your following you
know each polyp I mean I think look what
has Trump done really well he's learned
how to build a following absolutely
follow his twitter account and instagram
followers from the time six months
before he became president till now you
know me you know i dr if you think about
what he did right he pioneered the use
of radio to reach consumers right it was
a way to reach use mass reach mediums to
reach consumers aoc does it so it's not
a on either side of the aisle right a OC
and ramos look maybe very well maybe
it's not maybe unfortunately it's not
gonna be through paid media it's gonna
be through organic median you're gonna
have to build your own following maybe
that's better I don't think we I don't
think we know the the ultimate answer
yeah obviously you know there it is not
easy to build mass followings and
obviously sometimes those you end up
sort of moving towards the edges to
build that you know aggressive you know
you get heard it through the noise on
these platforms but I mean I'd say that
the ability to reach people through the
internet what's been enabled through all
of these different social media platform
is unparalleled to anything before I
mean you can reach a lot I mean the
reach of some of these politicians
social media accounts pals the number of
people that ever literally ever paid for
a newspaper or paid for television so
the ability to reach people all over the
world is unprecedented and that that's
really the opportunity obviously there's
fact-checking and lots of other issues
that you know we could get into it that
become problematic and you know what is
okay what is not okay I mean we just in
the last couple days we've gone to the
problem of you know before it was you
can't you can't you shouldn't
disseminate things that are knowingly
false or that change the meaning of
somebody now the question is is if you
change the order that something happened
in is it okay you know even if all of
the events actually happened can you if
you change the order of those things to
distort the ultimate implication is that
bad or you know who sets the rules and
you're seeing Twitter and everyone is
trying to hear look the Internet's
moving as we know the internet moves it
at incredible speed regulation not just
in this country but all over the world
moves at a much slower pace and it's
just it's very hard to understand how
whose sets the rules for these these
applications and and I have no good
answers yeah well I think it's a good
enough answer by itself before we wrap
up I always talk about two things one is
Bitcoin and one is aliens
any thoughts on Bitcoin I think the
payments overall you know I just think
about payments overall for any form of
media making it easier to transact
especially on a cross-border especially
you know think about developing
countries countries that may not have
stable currencies I think there are
certainly interesting potentials and you
look at why Facebook's doing Libre and
you know why companies like Spotify have
been interested in it and I think
there's the world's a big place and as
you look to grow from what we think of
as a very kind of us centric view of the
world of media and realize that you know
just look at last night right I mean
look at what won the Academy Award in
parasite there's a massive world of
incredible content music audio and
everything and beyond and gaming the
ability to shift to some form of
Universal currency is really interesting
across all of these forms of media and I
I don't think like I think we're still a
ways away from this being common and but
it's you know it has the potential to
solve you know real challenges you know
if you if I think about you know even
the early days of Netflix one of their
greatest challenges when they expanded
outside the US they went you know their
first market they went to was was Latin
America South America and you know
dealing with credit cards and payment
processors and all that was really
complicated and challenging and you know
I think again in the ultimate success
story of crypto in general hopefully you
solve a lot of those issues and I'm
definitely not the expert but I'm
certainly thinking about it from that
lens of like how do you solve real-world
business problems to make it easier for
the world's population to transact yeah
that's one of the most rational answers
from somebody who's not in the crypto
world I've heard so that was good and
then aliens I mean look I love the movie
aliens Sigourney Weaver was on stage at
the Oscars and I absolutely loved the
movie aliens will I comment on the
presence of aliens I have no idea but I
really hope there's life outside of our
solar system
why do you hope that there's life out I
just think it's hard to believe that
we're the only ones in the entire solar
system that you know have evolved into
you know humans but you know I think
that's fair I am ds-1 letting you ask me
one question what uh what he got for me
it's been fun what's your favorite what
are you watching right now what am i
watching so I don't watch anything
religiously what's the what's the last
series you binge so two of them one that
I chose to watch the one that I was
forced to watch this is your fiance
forced you uh cheer she she was a
divorced you so everyone let's so here's
the point everyone is watching cheer
like everyone listening to this podcast
know somebody if they're not and it
speaks to this whole thing when people
say there's nothing to watch on Netflix
when nobody's watching the content
should complete [ __ ] exactly yeah
exactly it when here's what here's
what's crazy if she was here here's what
she would tell you yeah when she first
started watching I was like I don't want
to watch this as stupid you know I'm
like playing on microphone all that
stuff by the end on my eyelid area stop
screwing around right so you get you get
sucked in and then what what is the only
show that I watch you want to watch
just religiously every season was it
acts capital billions billions oh yeah
so and and you want to know how I watch
it I do I tell me you steal it have
Amazon Prime okay no I signed up for
Showtime I watch it and then I cancel
Showtime right and then I wait and then
the other thing I do is you watch it
week to week live or do you wait for it
to end I was just gonna say I wait for
it to end and I binge it usually I tried
to in a weekend usually takes kind of
four days more the definition of why
media has a broad businesses in so much
trouble is that you move you know even
show time which tries to space out a
show like billions over you know
whatever ten weeks I just wait the
reality is most content doesn't need to
be watched live like you don't really
need you know maybe you know Game of
Thrones probably was pop culture enough
where you wanted to be part of that
conversation the morning after I would
say this probably on one hand that many
shows that exist that are so short into
pop culture now that you need to watch
week to week live and the reality is
everything else I mean I know lots of
people who are just starting you and it
came out two years ago like so this
whole idea that you know that whole
change of behavior mmm is a huge problem
because you're a horrible Showtime
customer because you sign up for a month
whether you pay that whatever you know
ten dollars doesn't matter there used to
be you being a full year subscriber oh
yeah they make more money off of me than
HBO and all the other subscriptions cuz
I don't subscribe to any of those but
they definitely what they are using a
subscriber you're a bad customer
absolutely in there and a problem that
the only way to solve it is to add a lot
more content and diversify and that's
why HBO is going from HBO to HBO max
because they need a lot more content to
prevent you from doing that the other
thing too that I don't know enough about
how TV series used to get produced but
like something like friends or whatever
to me it seems like it was much more
persistent like every single week week
in week out and there were seasons well
they were 22 episodes because they had
to get you from September through May
yeah right they had to get you there and
and then only the leaves why are only 90
days off of direct right yeah but now
the idea is let's create shows that are
sometimes as few as six or seven
episodes and the beauty of that is it
allows for movies to
who wouldn't normally take breaks from
shooting - didn't have time for 22 weeks
but might have room for eight weeks to
film you know a six or seven episode
series and so it actually is the
creative loves it
I think the consumers like because
you're not kind of forcing overly long
seasons where I mean look I think
seasons are gonna be shorter like you
don't I mean how many shows need five or
six seasons most things get pretty bad
after I mean the first few seasons of
shows are generally the best and then it
gets really hard to keep it well you
create it kill off so many characters or
Haydn look I think there's probably a
lot of people even on Game of Thrones
fans who would go I wish it had ended a
year sooner like it you know they could
have condensed it a little bit and ended
it sooner like I think that's one of the
other things you're seeing now is
episode orders are gonna be shorter
contents gonna be more condensed you're
hopefully gonna try to make better
shorter series both in episodes and
seasons to keep people interested where
can people find light shed we are I mean
on light shed I'm rich at light shed TMT
calm the websites light shed TMT calm
we're a subscription site but on Twitter
were just rich light shed anyone can
follow us my colleagues Brandon like
Brando what light shed and Walt light
shed we're all on Twitter we're pretty
active we'd love to engage with your
audience in this dialogue and hope to
come back I I can say this he can't but
uh I probably there's two people I
learned the most about media business
investing excetera you and Matthew Ball
so you guys are killing it so I
appreciate all the things I'm gonna bait
actively well that's what part of the
the value of it right is as you guys go
at it so it's awesome but thanks so much
for coming to do this and watched it
again thank you